OK, this just in. Sometimes things are not what they seem. Big news, I know. Here's an interesting example of it.
好的，插播一条消息。有时事物并非表面看起来那样。我知道，这是个大新闻。这里就有一个有趣的例子。
When Damien Cave moved to Mexico and started reporting there for The New York Times, a few months in, he noticed that when he would get onto an airplane and flip through the in-flight magazine, there would be these ads for tourists-- you know, those glossy, beautiful pictures of mountains, and river rafting, and nature, and "come visit" kinds of ads-- for places that he knew were centers of drug violence and gang violence.
当达米恩·凯夫搬到墨西哥并开始为《纽约时报》进行报道时，几个月后，他注意到每当他登上飞机并翻阅机上杂志时，总会有针对游客的广告——你知道，就是那些色彩鲜艳、美不胜收的照片，展示着山脉、漂流和自然风光，标语写着“快来旅游吧”——而这些地方他明明知道是贩毒和帮派暴力的中心。
I mean, it basically became the standard operating procedure for state after state. As the violence moved, the ads popped up in new places.
我的意思是，这基本成了州与州之间默认的操作规程。随着暴力活动转移，这些广告就会在新的地方冒出来。
And at some point it occurred to him, maybe these ads could be a useful reporting tool.
在某个时刻，他突然想到，也许这些广告可以成为一种有用的报道工具。
You know, Mexico is a place that there's just no transparency. And the government never gave us reliable statistics on deaths and murders. And over time, I started to just realize, OK, if there's a state or a location that's spending a lot of money in a magazine to tell me how beautiful it is, it must be pretty messed up.
你知道，墨西哥是一个完全没有透明度的地方。政府从来不会给我们提供可靠的死亡和谋杀统计数据。随着时间的推移，我开始意识到，好吧，如果有一个州或某个地方花大价钱在杂志上吹嘘自己有多美，那它一定出了严重的问题。
And so I remember getting on a flight and there was a spread for Vera Cruz, which was a state that was a beach state. It seemed fine, at least as far as we knew at that time.
我记得有一次搭乘航班，上面有一个关于韦拉克鲁斯的跨页广告，那是一个海滨州。至少在我们当时所知范围内，它看起来还不错。
Mm hm.
嗯。
Then I started to sort of dig in a little deeper. And it turns out it was about to explode with all these killings of local journalists, with this whole sort of drug war episode that turned it into this complete just hotbed of violence.
然后我开始深入挖掘。结果发现，它正处于爆发边缘，当地记者的遇害事件此起彼伏，整个毒品战争让它彻底变成了暴力温床。
And the ad actually sent you reporting on Vera Cruz?
所以那个广告反而成了你调查韦拉克鲁斯的线索？
It did, and Michoacan, too. Like, Michoacan is this state that produces most of the limes we get in the United States, all kinds of avocados. It's this agricultural, beautiful place.
确实如此，米却肯州也是。米却肯州生产美国大部分的青柠和各种鳄梨。那是一个农业发达、风景优美的地方。
And the ad that I saw was emphasizing that. It was green. It was lush. It was this place that, you know, it looked gorgeous. It looked like the best parts of California that you would want to go visit. And I knew that it was a state that was a little bit troubled.
我看到的那个广告就在强调这一点。它满眼绿色，郁郁葱葱。那地方看起来太棒了，简直就像加州那些你想去旅游的最佳景点。但我知道那是一个有点麻烦的州。
But that ad sort of said to me, OK, it must be even more troubled than you think. And sure enough, when I got there, this was a state that became this meth capital and this hotbed of vigilantism. But when I saw the ads, that's when I knew, OK, now it's time to go.
但那个广告对我来说，就像是在说：好吧，这里的情况肯定比你想象的还要糟糕。果然，当我到那里时，发现这个州已经成了冰毒之都和治安自卫队的温床。但当我看到那些广告时，我就知道，好吧，现在是时候动身了。
That is, like, the least effective propaganda imaginable. You are getting exactly the opposite message from the ads than the thing they're trying to get across.
这简直是你能想象出的最拙劣的宣传手段。你从广告中得到的讯息与他们试图传达的内容完全相反。
True. I mean, it became a joke among some of us-- other reporters in the office too-- of, well, this is clearly a place where we should start looking.
没错。我的意思是，这在我们中间——包括办公室的其他记者——成了一个笑话，大家都觉得，好吧，这显然是我们该开始调查的地方。
Damien never investigated why state after state would take out these ads. But he suspects they weren't really even targeted at tourists, these expensive photo spreads.
达米恩从未调查过为什么一个又一个州会刊登这些广告。但他怀疑，这些昂贵的照片跨页根本就不是针对游客的。
He assumes the ads were made by government officials who were trying to reassure business people and local people -- "OK, everything is fine. We got it under control. Nothing to see here." The ads were for them.
他推测这些广告是政府官员制作的，他们试图安抚商人和当地民众——“好了，一切都好。我们在掌控局面。没什么好看的。”这些广告是给他们看的。
And a little bit for their own government. I think it's a way for the politicians to signal to their bosses, "hey, look, I'm working on this. I'm making sure that people are saying what they should be saying about my state.
还有一点是给他们自己的政府看的。我认为这是一种政客向他们的上司发出信号的方式：“嘿，你看，我正在处理这件事。我正在确保人们在谈论我所在的州时，说的是他们该说的话。”
And it won't hurt you, Mr. President, or it won't hurt you, head of the party, because we're doing this for all of us together."
“总统先生，这对您没有坏处；或者党魁先生，这对您也没有坏处，因为我们是在为我们大家共同的利益行事。”
Damien has spent a lot of time also in Cuba. And he says in Cuba, like in Mexico, there are subtle meanings contained inside government messages, but only if you understand the nuances.
达米恩也花了很多时间在古巴。他说在古巴，就像在墨西哥一样，政府消息中包含着微妙的含义，但前提是你得理解其中的细微差别。
In some ways, propaganda is like poetry. You need to know how to read it. And some people read it and see it only on one level. And then lots of other people see it and read it at a secondary level that's deeper and that may speak to the exact opposite of what it says on that first reading.
在某些方面，宣传就像诗歌。你需要懂得如何解读它。有些人读了它只看到表面一层。而许多其他人则能从更深层的第二层面去解读，这可能与第一遍阅读时所传达的意思截然相反。
The Cubans will read Granma , the main state organ, for all kinds of little things that they'll see in there that I won't see. And so the slightest mention of President Obama, and the degree to which the negativity is calibrated, they can see, oh, this is a sign that the government is warming up to the United States.
古巴人会阅读国家主要喉舌《格拉玛报》，从中找出各种我看不出来的蛛丝马迹。所以，哪怕是最轻微地提到奥巴马总统，以及负面评价的程度如何调整，他们都能看出来：哦，这是一个政府正在向美国示好的信号。
Even if it's negative, by the degree of negativity, they know how to interpret that. It's complicated. It may seem really simple. But I think that people inside these countries are the best interpreters of their own propaganda.
即使是负面的，通过负面的程度，他们也知道如何解读。这很复杂。看起来可能很简单。但我认为，这些国家内部的人民才是解读他们自己宣传的最佳人选。
And the great irony, it seems to me, is the government, in an effort to tell its people what they think they need to hear, they often underestimate the people's ability to deconstruct it and understand it.
在我看来，最大的讽刺是，政府为了告诉人民他们认为人民需要听的话，往往低估了人民解构和理解这些信息的能力。
Propaganda is like poetry. It is complexity in the form of simplicity, if you know how to read it. And today on our program, we have three stories that illustrate that principle-- one from China, one from South America, and one from right here in our own United States of America.
宣传就像诗歌。如果你懂得如何解读，它就是形式上的简单与内涵上的复杂。今天在我们的节目中，我们有三个故事可以说明这个原则——一个来自中国，一个来自南美，还有一个就发生在我们自己的美利坚合众国。
Two of these stories are about propaganda that was so ingenious and worked so well, it's kind of incredible, actually. It's This American Life from WBEZ Chicago. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us, comrades.
其中两个故事关于宣传，其巧妙程度和效果之好，简直令人难以置信。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请和我们待在一起，同志们。
Act One, "Guerrilla Marketing." Well, the nation of Colombia has been at war for more than 50 years. And if you've followed this even a little bit, you know that the main rebel group fighting the government is called the Revolutionary Armed Forces of Colombia. The Spanish acronym for that is FARC, spelled F-A-R-C.
第一幕，“游击营销”。哥伦比亚这个国家已经陷入战争超过50年了。如果你稍微关注过这一点，你就会知道与政府作战的主要反叛组织名为“哥伦比亚革命武装力量”。西班牙语的首字母缩写是FARC，拼写为F-A-R-C。
The FARC are a leftist guerrilla contingent, sometimes funding their operations through ransoms from kidnappings, or through drug running. Though it should be said that there have been rightist paramilitary forces aligned with the government who have been involved in similar activities.
哥伦比亚革命武装力量（FARC）是一支左翼游击队，有时通过绑架赎金或贩毒来筹集资金。当然也应该说，也有与政府结盟的右翼准军事力量参与了类似的活动。
One byproduct of the war-- and I say this. I don't want to sound glib or insensitive. But really, the war has yielded a brand of propaganda that is so ambitious and ornate-- well, you'll hear. Producer Sean Cole explains.
战争的一个副产品——我这么说并不想显得轻率或麻木。但实际上，这场战争产出了一种极其宏大且华丽的宣传——好吧，待会儿你就会听到了。制片人肖恩·科尔为您介绍。
And this particular propaganda campaign began about 10 years ago, when an advertising executive in Colombia named Jose Miguel Sokoloff was offered what had to be the most demanding account of his career.
这一特殊的宣传运动始于大约10年前，当时哥伦比亚的一位广告高管何塞·米格尔·索科洛夫得到了他职业生涯中最具挑战性的客户。
The client was the government of Colombia. The assignment, convince as many FARC guerrilla fighters as possible to demobilize, to quit the FARC. In short, please help us end this war.
客户是哥伦比亚政府。任务是：说服尽可能多的FARC游击队员退伍，离开FARC。简而言之，请帮我们结束这场战争。
A word about Jose-- he's deeply principled and earnest. And if you Google image him, you'll see a lot of v-neck sweaters. His ad agency-- Lowe SSP3 it's called-- has been around since the mid '90s. His clients are not usually the defense ministries of South American countries.
关于何塞的一点介绍——他非常注重原则且真诚。如果你去谷歌搜索他的照片，你会看到很多V领毛衣。他的广告公司——名为Lowe SSP3——自90年代中期就已经存在了。他的客户通常不是南美国家的国防部。
We just finished a beautiful project for Lifebuoy, which is an antibacterial soap in India.
我们刚为Lifebuoy完成了一个漂亮的策划，那是印度的一种抗菌肥皂。
They've done ads for dog food, bug repellent. But at the same time, he says, the fundamental mission, whether he's selling that stuff or trying to demobilize guerrillas, is still the same.
他们做过狗粮、防虫喷雾的广告。但同时，他说，无论是推销这些产品还是试图让游击队员退伍，其根本使命都是一样的。
I think about change, about how to change a behavior, how to change a perception. That's the business we're in. We're in the business of changing minds.
我思考的是改变，关于如何改变一种行为，如何改变一种认知。这就是我们所处的行业。我们从事的是改变思想的生意。
A word about the FARC guerrillas-- they're a heavily-armed fighting force of, at this moment, more than 7,000 rebel soldiers. They wear fatigues, live mainly in jungle encampments.
关于FARC游击队的一点介绍——他们是一支全副武装的作战力量，目前有超过7000名反叛士兵。他们穿着迷彩服，主要生活在丛林营地里。
They're what you think of when you think organized revolutionary militia. I should say, Jose and his company had done a little bit of political work before this. And Jose himself almost takes the conflict personally.
他们就是你想到有组织的革命民兵时所联想到的形象。我应该说，何塞和他的公司在此之前做过一点政治工作。何塞本人几乎把这场冲突当成了私事。
It's been going on as long as he's been alive. He always says he hasn't lived one day of peace in his country. Still, getting guerrillas to demobilize isn't exactly selling beer to soccer fans. They're either true believers in the cause or, more frequently, captives themselves.
这场冲突和他出生以来一样长。他总说他在自己的国家没过过一天和平的日子。尽管如此，让游击队员退伍并不等同于向足球迷卖啤酒。他们要么是事业的忠实信徒，要么更多时候，他们自己就是囚徒。
If you try to escape the FARC and they catch you, they'll kill you, which is why the government has set up a reentry program to support and protect former guerrillas-- and, of course, to get information out of them.
如果你试图从FARC逃跑而他们抓住了你，他们会杀了你，这就是为什么政府设立了一个重返社会计划来支持和保护前游击队员——当然，也是为了从他们那里获取情报。
Jose and company figured their first step was to gather some intell themselves. And so they interviewed a bunch of guerrillas who had just demobilized to find out what makes someone quit the FARC.
何塞和他的公司认为第一步是收集情报。于是他们采访了一群刚退伍的游击队员，找出是什么让人离开FARC。
We heard a story of a man who left the guerrilla because he was ordered to kill a couple that had been accused of something. And he thought they were innocent.
我们听到一个男人的故事，他离开游击队是因为他接到命令要杀死一对被指控某事的夫妇。而他认为他们是无辜的。
And they were very, very young. And he remembered hearing the girl saying, "kill me first so that I don't have to see my boyfriend die."
而且他们非常非常年轻。他记得听到那个女孩说：“先杀我，这样我就不用看着我的男友死去。”
It's important to note the government forces have been just as brutal.
重要的是要指出，政府军也同样残暴。
A lot of women get out of the guerrilla because they want to have a family. And in the guerrilla, you're not allowed to have a family. So you have to abort any pregnancy.
很多女性离开游击队是因为她们想要有个家。而在游击队里，你不被允许拥有家庭。所以你必须流产任何胎儿。
And that's a forced thing. So we heard stories of women who had been through the procedure two or three times. And they said, that's it.
这是一种强制行为。所以我们听到了那些经历过两三次这种手术的女性的故事。她们说，受够了。
Oh, my god.
噢，天哪。
Yeah, these are not beautiful stories. I could go on. And your reaction would be "oh my god, oh my god, oh my god."
是啊，这些故事都不好听。我可以继续说下去。而你的反应会是“天哪，天哪，天哪”。
And after gathering all of those stories, they picked three of them and made each one into a 30-second TV ad. Apparently a lot of guerrilla camps are outfitted with satellite dishes so they can watch the football matches. The ads were professional and polished, just like the work the company's always done.
收集完所有这些故事后，他们选出了其中三个，并将其制作成30秒的电视广告。显然，许多游击队营地都配有卫星天线，这样他们就可以看足球比赛。这些广告制作专业且精良，就像该公司一直以来的作品一样。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（讲西班牙语）
He's is saying, "One day I was ordered to execute a couple that was unjustly accused of treason. It was hard. They were just children. She asked to die first, to not see her boyfriend dead."
他说：“有一天我接到命令，要处决一对被不公正指控叛国罪的夫妇。这太难了。他们简直还是孩子。她请求先死，为了不看着她的男友死去。”
But we made a mistake. We did not actually use the guerrillas' voices. We used actors. And they immediately saw through that. And they said, this is not real. This is not how we speak.
但我们犯了一个错误。我们并没有真正使用游击队员的声音。我们用了演员。而他们立刻就看穿了这一点。他们说，这不是真的。我们不是这样说话的。
They're not dumb.
他们并不傻。
Right. It's somebody else telling this stupid story.
没错。是别人在讲述这个愚蠢的故事。
Right.
对。
So when we heard that, we went back to the archives of all the stories we had recorded. And we asked permission of the guerrillas who had told us these stories to use their voices and put them on the air, slightly modified. And then that started being much more effective.
所以当我们听到这些后，我们回到所有我们录制的故事档案中。我们请求那些讲述故事的游击队员许可，使用他们的真实声音并进行轻微修饰后播出。之后，效果好多了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（讲西班牙语）
She says, "They were going to force me to get an abortion, but I didn't let them. So they punished me by making me clear paths with a machete for six months."
她说：“他们要强迫我堕胎，但我没让他们得逞。于是他们惩罚我，让我用砍刀清理了六个月的道路。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（讲西班牙语）
They made about 100 of these radio ads in the first year, just former guerrillas talking to current guerrillas about why they should quit. The ads were mainly targeting the foot soldiers, the foundation of the FARC.
第一年他们制作了大约100条这样的广播广告，都是前游击队员在向现役游击队员讲述他们为什么应该退出。这些广告主要针对的是步兵，也就是FARC的基础。
And Jose says it's safe to estimate 2,000 of those lower ranking guerrillas have demobilized since his company started with the radio spots. But it wasn't enough, he says, in part because the FARC leaders were telling their soldiers that the government was forcing the ex-guerrillas to say those things in the ads.
何塞说，保守估计，自他的公司开始投放广播广告以来，已经有2000名低级游击队员退伍。但他说这还不够，部分原因是FARC领导人告诉士兵，政府是在胁迫前游击队员说出那些广告里的内容。
The reason these people are sending you these messages is because they have a gun to their head. And if they don't send these messages, they're going to get killed. So don't believe these messages. These messages are worthless.
这些人给你们发这些信息是因为他们被枪顶着头。如果他们不发这些信息，他们就会被杀。所以别相信这些信息。这些信息一文不值。
So they're working a kind of anti-propaganda on the guerrillas on that side.
所以他们也在针对游击队员进行一种反宣传。
As they should. As they should. Because I think it's their obligation to do so.
他们理应如此。理应如此。因为我认为这是他们的义务。
And this is one of the interesting things about Jose as a propagandist. He's clear-eyed about the fact that this is a war and that both sides are supposed to try and win it. He does have his own personal beliefs.
这就是何塞作为一名宣传专家有趣的地方。他清醒地认识到这是一场战争，双方都应该努力去赢得它。他确实有自己的个人信仰。
He told me he thinks leftist experiments in Latin America haven't worked. But he says all he wants is for Colombia to be the kind of country where people on the left and people on the right just argue all the time, without killing each other.
他告诉我，他认为拉丁美洲的左翼实验行不通。但他说，他想要的只是哥伦比亚成为一个左派和右派可以不断争论，却不会互相残杀的国家。
And then, in 2010, Jose's team learned something that would totally radicalize the way they did this work. One of his young colleagues noticed it first. Looking at the data, demobilization numbers always went up around Christmas. They peaked actually.
接着，在2010年，何塞的团队学到了一些彻底改变他们工作方式的东西。他的一位年轻同事先注意到的。查看数据后发现，退伍人数总是在圣诞节前后上升。实际上达到了顶峰。
Guerrillas wanted to be home for Christmas. In war terminology, December was a window of vulnerability for the FARC. Now Jose and his team could have whipped up a Christmas campaign and put it on TV, or on the radio. But they didn't do that.
游击队员们想回家过圣诞节。用战争术语来说，12月是FARC的一个脆弱窗口。现在何塞和他的团队本可以赶制一个圣诞广告放到电视或广播上。但他们没这么做。
"We decided to try something completely lateral and different."
“我们决定尝试一些完全横向且不同的东西。”
This recording is from a TED Talk Jose gave last year.
这段录音来自何塞去年做的TED演讲。
"Christmas lights. So Christmas lights. And you're saying what the hell is this guy going to talk about? OK, I am going to talk about gigantic trees that we put in nine strategic pathways in the jungle, covered with Christmas lights.
“圣诞灯饰。就是圣诞灯饰。你们在想这人到底要说什么？好吧，我要谈论的是我们放置在丛林中九条战略路径上的巨型树木，上面挂满了圣诞灯饰。”
These trees were lit up at night. And they had a sign beside them."
“这些树在晚上亮着灯。旁边有一个牌子。”
A sign that only lit up when the guerrillas happened to walk by and trigger a motion sensor. It said--
一个只有当游击队员凑巧走过并触发动作感应器时才会亮起的牌子。上面写着——
"If Christmas can come to the jungle, you can come home. Demobilize. It's Christmas. Everything is possible."
“如果圣诞节可以来到丛林，你也可以回家。退伍吧。现在是圣诞节。一切皆有可能。”
By gigantic trees, Jose means maybe 75 feet high, all wrapped in whitish blue lights, from top to bottom. It was really impressive. They called it "Operation Christmas," which might make it sound like Linus and Lucy and Charlie Brown marching into the jungles of Colombia to decorate a spruce.
关于巨型树木，何塞指的是大约75英尺高，从头到尾都缠满了白色和蓝色灯光的树。这真的很壮观。他们称之为“圣诞行动”，这听起来可能像是莱纳斯、露西和查理·布朗走进哥伦比亚丛林去装饰一棵云杉。
And it kind of was like that, except replace Linus and Lucy and Charlie Brown with the army of Colombia descending in Black Hawk helicopters.
确实有点像那样，除了把莱纳斯、露西和查理·布朗换成乘坐黑鹰直升机降落在哥伦比亚丛林的哥伦比亚军队。
But as spectacular as the trees were, they were just meant to be a tease. Jose says it was just a little taste of Christmas.
但尽管树木很壮观，它们只是为了作为一个诱饵。何塞说这只是圣诞节的一点点滋味。
But that's it. There's no friends. There's no party. There's no aguardiente, which is a drink that we have here.
“但就是这样。没有朋友。没有派对。没有 aguardiente（一种我们这里的酒）。”
Mm hm.
嗯。
There is nothing. There's no fun. You're just walking by and hoping that the army doesn't see you and doesn't shoot you. And that was incredibly powerful. That effort alone demobilized 331 guerrillas.
“什么都没有。没有乐趣。你只是路过，希望军队没看见你，没向你开枪。而那本身就极其有力。”仅仅是那项行动就让331名游击队员退伍了。
Really?
真的吗？
Which at the time was roughly 5% of the whole guerrilla army.
那在当时大约占了整个游击队总人数的5%。
And that wasn't even necessarily the result of seeing the trees, Jose says. Sometimes the guerrillas just heard about them and decided to demobilize. His company sent us a few quotes they'd transcribed from guerrillas who demobilized during "Operation Christmas."
何塞说，这甚至不一定是看到树木的结果。有时游击队员只是听说了它们，就决定退伍。他的公司发给我们一些他们从“圣诞行动”期间退伍的游击队员口中整理出来的引语。
"We knew all of the strategies the government had done," one of them said. "But we never expected something like this." Another said that, surprisingly, his commander wasn't even angry about the Christmas trees. Quote, "It was different to the other propaganda we had seen. He was touched."
“我们知道政府所做的所有策略，”其中一人说。“但我们从没预料到这样的事。”另一个人说，令人惊讶的是，他的指挥官甚至没有因为圣诞树而生气。引用：“这和我们之前见过的其他宣传完全不同。他被打动了。”
So Jose and his crew knew they were on to something. And after winning that first Christmas, they were able to perfect and hone the formula even more sharply, because now they had these newly demobilized guerrillas to talk to.
所以何塞和他的团队知道他们抓住了要点。在赢得了那个第一个圣诞节之后，他们能够更精准地打磨完善这个公式，因为现在他们有了这些刚退伍的游击队员可以谈话。
Eventually, when we talked to the guerrillas that had left, at the time, they said the trees are all good. They were amazing. We love them. Thank you very much. And they were very effective, but the thing is that we are not walking as much as you think. We move in the rivers.
最终，当我们和那时已经离开的游击队员交谈时，他们说树木棒极了。它们太神奇了。我们喜欢它们。非常感谢。而且它们非常有效，但问题是我们并没有像你们想象的那样在走路。我们在河流中移动。
The rivers are the highways of the jungle, in Colombia. And Jose's company could have done what you do on a highway and put up billboards. But why do that when you can do something far more insane?
河流是哥伦比亚丛林的高速公路。何塞的公司本可以像在公路上那样树立广告牌。但当你可以做一些更疯狂的事情时，为什么要那么做呢？
The 2011 Christmas demobilization campaign was called "Operation Rivers of Light." Jose and company went to towns and villages and gathered little toys and trinkets, notes. They mostly had people write notes to the guerrilla fighters. And they put all of those things into plastic, glowing, purple balls, a little bit bigger than a softball.
2011年的圣诞退伍运动被称为“光明之河行动”。何塞和团队去了城镇和乡村，收集了小玩具、小饰品和纸条。他们主要让人们给游击队员写信。他们把所有这些东西放进塑料的、发光的紫色球里，比垒球大一点。
They floated almost 7,000 of those balls onto the rivers of Colombia, and all of which lit up at night, like a terrestrial galaxy. The tops of the balls were transparent so the FARC soldiers would see what was inside of them when they pulled them out the water.
他们把近7000个那样的球漂流在哥伦比亚的河流上，夜晚全部亮起，就像一片地上的银河。球的顶部是透明的，这样FARC士兵从水里捞起它们时就能看到里面装的是什么。
And the Christmas after that, they decided they weren't just going to bring lights to the jungle. They were going to use lights to try to lead guerrillas out of the jungle. They shone huge spotlights up into the sky, the way they did in Manhattan after 9/11 to symbolize the missing towers.
在那之后的那个圣诞节，他们决定不仅要给丛林带来光明。他们要利用光线引导游击队员走出丛林。他们向天空投射巨大的探照灯，就像9/11事件后在曼哈顿做的那样，以象征失踪的双子塔。
Except in this case, the message was, "Guerrilla, this Christmas follow the light that will guide you to your family and your freedom." They called it "Operation Bethlehem."
只不过在这种情况下，信息是：“游击队员，今年圣诞节跟着那道光，它会引导你回到家人身边和自由中。”他们称之为“伯利恒行动”。
God, there's a huge amount of staging and production involved in all of this.
天哪，所有这些都需要进行大量的策划和制作。
Yes, there is. There is because I frankly believe that everything you do needs to be beautiful. The only element that cannot lack is beauty, making sure you like what you're seeing. You cannot do ugly stuff.
是的，确实需要。因为我坦率地相信，你所做的一切都需要美。唯一不能缺少的就是美，确保你喜欢你所看到的。你不能做丑陋的东西。
When you see all these lights floating down the river, slowly floating down towards you, you can't escape the thought of, this is a beautiful thing. Regardless of what it is, how beautiful is it?
当你看到所有这些灯光漂浮在河上，缓缓向你漂来，你无法逃避一个想法：这是一件美好的事物。无论它是什么，它有多美？
Because had it been a thing that is not beautiful, I probably wouldn't have looked at it. I would have said, this is trash floating down the river. But if it's a beautiful thing that's coming down, it's coming down in numbers, then I'm drawn to it. I'm interested.
因为如果它是一件不美好的事物，我可能根本就不会看它。我会说，那是漂在河里的垃圾。但如果是一个美好的事物漂下来，而且数量很多，那我就被吸引了。我感兴趣。
But along with beauty, Jose says one of the other key ingredients is surprise, and has to be something they've never done before. So after three Christmases in a row, he and his fellow guerrilla marketers all looked at each other and said--
但何塞说，除了美之外，另一个关键要素是惊喜，必须是他们从未做过的事情。所以连续三个圣诞节后，他和他的伙伴游击营销人员看着对方说——
Enough of the lights. We're not going to keep throwing lights at the jungle. Let's think of something different. And it came across because the circumstances changed.
“灯饰够了。我们不会继续往丛林里扔灯饰了。让我们想想别的东西。”而灵感之所以出现，是因为环境变了。
That is, in 2012, the two sides began peace talks in Cuba. There had been peace negotiations between the revolutionaries and the government before. But this time they seemed more promising.
也就是说，2012年，双方在古巴开始了和平谈判。之前革命者和政府之间也有过和平谈判。但这一次看起来更有希望。
So to Jose's thinking, the concerns of the FARC were different now. It wasn't so much is this a winnable war anymore, or is this life worth living. It was more, this war's probably going to end anyway. We're all going to end up disbanding. And will they take me in again back home? Will my family still accept me?
所以按照何塞的看法，FARC的顾虑现在不同了。这不再仅仅是这是不是一场能赢的战争，或者这样的生活是否值得。更多的是，这场战争可能终归会结束。我们最终都会解散。他们还会接受我回家吗？我的家人还会接受我吗？
And that's when they dropped probably their biggest emotional bomb to date, a campaign they called simply "Mothers' Voices." They found 37 mothers of guerrilla fighters who were willing to give them pictures of those fighters as children.
就在那时，他们投下了迄今为止可能最大的情感炸弹，一场他们简单地称为“母亲的声音”的运动。他们找到了37位愿意提供那些战士童年照片的游击队员的母亲。
And it was important that they gave us pictures of the kids when they were small, because in order to protect them, we needed to make sure that only the person in the picture would be able to recognize himself.
而且很重要的一点是，他们给了我们孩子小时候的照片，因为为了保护他们，我们需要确保只有照片里的那个人才能认出自己。
And the message was, "Before you were a guerrilla, you were my child."
标语是：“在你成为游击队员之前，你是我的孩子。”
That's what it said on the poster.
海报上就是这么写的。
That's what it said on the poster. "Before you were a guerrilla, you were my child. Come back this Christmas. I'm waiting for you."
海报上就是这么写的。“在你成为游击队员之前，你是我的孩子。今年圣诞节回来吧。我在等你。”
They printed up thousands of these posters and hung them in towns that the guerrillas moved through and nailed them to trees as well. The mothers campaign was really moving-- simple, no lights attached-- proving you don't have to do something huge and carnivalistic to win someone over, to change their behavior.
他们打印了数千张这样的海报，挂在游击队员会经过的城镇，也钉在树上。母亲运动真的非常感人——简单，没有灯光——证明了你不需要做一些巨大的、狂欢式的东西来赢得人心，来改变人们的行为。
I mean, the goal of propaganda is usually to appeal to emotions. But this was on another level. It was so personal-- in a couple of cases, so specific to the person receiving the message.
我的意思是，宣传的目标通常是诉诸情感。但这达到了另一个层面。它太个人化了——在某些情况下，对接收信息的人来说太具体了。
There's this one story Jose always tells as he goes around talking about this work, and it's my favorite one. It doesn't have to do with the Christmas trees or the floating balls or the mothers campaign. And it takes place way back, when all they were doing were the radio ads.
何塞在谈论这项工作时总是喜欢讲一个故事，这是我最喜欢的一个。它与圣诞树、漂浮的球或母亲运动无关。它发生在很久以前，当时他们只做广播广告的时候。
There was a guerrilla guy whose combat name was Giovanni Andres. And a few years into his service they recruited a girl into the guerrilla.
有一个游击队员，战斗名叫乔瓦尼·安德烈斯。他服役几年后，游击队招募了一个女孩进来。
Into his unit. I've been meaning to say-- women make up 30% of the FARC forces. And they fight right alongside the men, dressed in fatigues, brandishing rifles. Anyway, this boy and this girl--
进入他的部队。我一直想说——女性占FARC部队的30%。她们和男人并肩作战，穿着迷彩服，挥舞着步枪。不管怎样，这个男孩和女孩——
They fell in love. And they had this beautiful relationship. And they spent most of their time, when they were alone, talking about what their life would be like and what their family would be like, and the kind of things young lovers talk about.
他们坠入爱河。他们拥有一段美好的感情。他们大多数时间，在独自一人时，都在谈论他们的生活会是什么样，他们的家庭会是什么样，以及年轻恋人谈论的那种事情。
Except for they're in the jungle and they're--
除了他们是在丛林里，而且他们——
Carrying guns. And they're patrolling. And they're going into combat, right. I remember him telling me that they always tried to go out when there was fighting, when there was a combat, that they always tried to go out together, so that they could protect each other. They could watch each other's back.
背着枪。他们在巡逻。他们在进行战斗，对吧。我记得他告诉我，当有战斗发生时，他们总是尝试一起出去，这样他们就能保护对方。他们能守护对方的后背。
But love is forbidden in the lower ranks of the guerrilla. So the couple was separated. One of them was sent to a camp far away. And so now, without her boyfriend, life in the FARC completely lost its hold on the girl. So she escaped, demobilized to the military reentry program, where she was interviewed by Jose's company.
但爱情在游击队的底层是被禁止的。所以这对恋人被分开了。其中一人被派到了很远的营地。所以现在，没有了男友，在FARC的生活对这个女孩来说完全失去了吸引力。于是她逃跑了，退伍进入了军事重返社会计划，在那里她接受了何塞公司的采访。
And she said, "I got out of the guerrilla because I had found the love of my life. And the love of my life could not be with me. And if I'm not going to be able to have the family and the love I want, I'm going to get out. And so I did."
她说：“我离开游击队是因为我找到了我一生挚爱。而我的一生挚爱却不能和我在一起。如果我不能拥有我想要的家庭和爱情，那我就要离开。于是我就离开了。”
And the thing is that, by chance, her boyfriend heard her voice. And he said "oh, my god. She got out. And I'm still here. What am I doing here?" So he got out. And his obsession was trying to find her, which eventually he did. He did.
而事情是，巧合之下，她的男友听到了她的声音。他说“噢，天哪。她出来了。我还在这里。我在这干什么？”于是他也出来了。他的执念就是试图找到她，最终他做到了。他真的做到了。
A reporter for the British paper The Independent wrote that he met the guy, Giovanni Andres, in 2010, and confirmed the story. I asked Jose if there was any way we could talk to him, or his girlfriend.
英国《独立报》的一位记者写道，他在2010年见到了这个名叫乔瓦尼·安德烈斯的家伙，并证实了这个故事。我问何塞我们是否有办法能和他们或者他的女友谈谈。
But so many years after leaving the reentry program, which is kind of like a witness protection program, former guerrillas get harder and harder to find. They fade back into society, which is what's supposed to happen. Anyway, it's very possible that they're still together, making good on all those plans they hatched in the jungle.
但在离开重返社会计划——这就像证人保护计划——那么多年后，前游击队员越来越难找到了。他们退回到社会中，这本来就是应该发生的事情。不管怎样，他们很有可能仍然在一起，兑现他们在丛林里谋划的所有计划。
Just beautiful. It's very poetic, if you think about it.
太美了。如果你思考一下，这非常诗意。
It is beautiful. It's really moving. I've also just never heard of propaganda playing such an integral role in a love story like that.
确实很美。真的很感人。我也从没听说过宣传在这样的爱情故事中扮演如此重要的角色。
Yeah, well, war is a human endeavor. And it's fought by human beings. And when humanity is removed from the equation, by one side or the other, I think the reinsertion of the human aspect gives you an edge.
是的，战争是一项人类的事业。它是由人类参与战斗的。而当人性被任何一方从等式中剔除时，我认为重新植入人性因素会给你带来优势。
Jose says this work has been unusual in a lot of ways. The client, of course, is an anomaly. And the audience he's trying to appeal to is unlike any he's had before. And normally in advertising, he says, you want the same clients to come back year after year and do more business with you.
何塞说这项工作在很多方面都很不寻常。客户当然是一个反常现象。而且他试图吸引的受众也是他从未遇到过的。通常在广告业，他说，你希望客户年复一年地回来，与你进行更多的业务往来。
And this is the only advertising campaign I've ever worked on where, if I'm successful, I will never need to do advertising like this again. I want my client to disappear.
而这是我工作过的唯一一个广告活动，如果我成功了，我将再也不需要做这样的广告。我希望我的客户消失。
To disappear.
消失。
Yeah.
是的。
This year, Jose's already getting a small taste of what that would be like. As part of the peace negotiations, the FARC has asked the government not to launch any big demobilizing campaigns this Christmas. For the first time in years, Jose and his team have Christmas off.
今年，何塞已经尝到了一点那样的滋味。作为和平谈判的一部分，FARC要求政府今年圣诞节不要发动任何大的退伍运动。这是多年来，何塞和他的团队第一次拥有圣诞节假期。
Sean Cole is one of the producers of our program.
肖恩·科尔是我们节目的制片人之一。
Act Two, "Not Our Town." Well, we just heard how jarring an experience it can be to happen upon a piece of propaganda-- a full blown, all out, no holds barred piece propaganda-- when you're not expecting anything like that at all.
第二幕，“不是我们的城镇”。好吧，我们刚才听到了偶然遇到一段宣传时会是多么令人不快的一种体验——当你在完全没预期的情况下，遇到一段全面铺开、毫无保留的宣传时。
That happened to a writer named Jon Mooallem recently, in a very different setting than a South American jungle.
一位名叫乔恩·穆阿勒姆的作家最近在与南美丛林截然不同的环境中经历了这件事。
This past spring, we went to see the end of the year musical for my daughter's after school program at a public school in San Francisco. It was an original work. And she had a tiny part, her first play.
今年春天，我们去观看我女儿在旧金山一所公立学校的课后项目的年终音乐剧。那是一部原创作品。她有个小角色，是她的第一部戏。
I don't know what I expected. But it wasn't this. Act one, scene one, opened on a sinister tech executive meeting with a corrupt mayor and San Francisco's board of supervisors.
我不知道我期待什么。但绝不是这个。第一幕第一场，开场是一场邪恶的科技高管与腐败市长及旧金山市监督委员会的会议。
He's pitching them a new branding campaign for the city. It's meant to distract citizens from San Francisco's widening socioeconomic inequality and simmering strife. My daughter was finishing kindergarten. She was six.
他正在向他们推销一个新的城市品牌宣传活动。旨在分散市民对旧金山日益扩大的社会经济不平等和暗流涌动的冲突的注意力。我女儿当时还在上幼儿园。她才六岁。
One elected official, played by a fifth grader, explains that everyone knows the city is struggling. A wave of tech money is driving up real estate prices and pushing people out. She describes it as a kind of civic identity crisis.
由五年级学生扮演的一位民选官员解释说，每个人都知道这座城市正在挣扎。一波科技资金正在推高房地产价格，并将人们赶出这里。她将其描述为一种公民身份危机。
A town that was once known as bastion of freedom, inclusion, individuality, is now known as a sterile playground for the rich.
一座曾经以自由、包容、个性堡垒而闻名的城镇，现在却被称为富人的无菌游乐场。
People are frustrated. They don't want to live in this sterile playground for the rich. That's why the city's called in this branding guy, a tech marketing guru named Ron Scraper, a master of his craft who could "sell water to an ocean," one kid says.
人们很沮丧。他们不想住在富人的无菌游乐场里。这就是为什么这座城市请来了这个品牌推广人，一位名为罗恩·斯克雷珀的科技营销大师，正如一个孩子所说，他是一位能“把水卖给海洋”的行业高手。
Scraper can't fix the city's gentrification problem. But he has cooked up a creative way to reframe it. "Sure," he says, "pitching his idea to the city government. No one can afford San Francisco's rental market anymore, or the $100 Uber rides." But-- and here's his new slogan--
斯克雷珀解决不了城市的中产阶级化问题。但他想出了一个创造性的方法来重新定义它。“当然，”他在向市政府推销他的想法时说，“没人再能负担得起旧金山的租赁市场，或者100美元的Uber车费。”但是——这是他的新口号——
San Francisco, where you can afford to dream.
旧金山，在这里你负担得起梦想。
The question is, can we afford this ad campaign? What's the damage?
问题是，我们负担得起这个广告活动吗？损失有多大？
[LAUGHING]
（笑声）
I'm sure we can afford it, right, Ron?
我相信我们负担得起，对吧，罗恩？
That's the mayor, a chuckling, feathery kid in an oversized suit. He loves the idea and suggests paying Ron Scraper's consulting fee by redirecting funds from city public schools and affordable housing. Suddenly music starts.
那是市长，一个穿着大码西装、咯咯笑的孩子。他喜欢这个主意，并建议通过从城市公立学校和保障性住房中调拨资金来支付罗恩·斯克雷珀的咨询费。突然，音乐响起。
Lines of dancing third graders flood the stage. They're holding iPads made out of cardboard and glitter. And they sing about looking down on the less fortunate people from expensive homes they just bought in a formerly working class neighborhood.
排成一排的三年级跳舞学生涌上舞台。他们拿着纸板和亮片做的iPad。他们唱着关于从他们刚在以前工人阶级街区买下的昂贵房子里俯视那些不幸的人们的故事。
[SINGING]
（唱歌）
"I bought a sleek condo for about $5 mil, right on top of Potrero Hill."
“我花大约500万买了一套时尚公寓，就在波特雷罗山顶上。”
[SINGING]
（唱歌）
At one point, the band slows down. And this angelically round faced child steps into a spotlight for his solo. You can see his face, straining to find his note.
在某个时刻，乐队慢了下来。这个天使般圆脸的孩子走到聚光灯下独唱。你可以看到他的脸，努力寻找音准。
[SINGING] We need a ray of light to clear the foggy sky.
（唱歌）我们需要一道光来驱散多雾的天空。
This place was perfect with sunny weather.
这个地方以前很完美，天气也很晴朗。
They're taking our city from behind our back.
他们在我们背后夺走我们的城市。
[SINGING] They're taking the souls of the wild and free. They're taking over, but they can't take me. Me! Me! Me! Me!
（唱歌）他们正在夺走野性与自由的灵魂。他们正在接管，但他们无法夺走我。我！我！我！我！
It's a San Francisco dream!
这是旧金山的梦！
So there they were, these blameless children, up there performing a kind of kiddie grotesque of the same exasperated conversation that all us parents were constantly having behind their backs, the conversation that more and more seemed to hang over every conversation in San Francisco, then inevitably spiraled into panicked Zillow searches for homes in Oakland, or Petaluma, or Portland.
所以他们就在那儿，这些无可指责的孩子们，站在舞台上表演一种儿童式的滑稽剧，内容就是我们这些家长们不断在他们背后进行的那些烦躁的谈话。那种谈话似乎笼罩着旧金山的每一次交谈，然后不可避免地演变成对奥克兰、佩塔卢马或波特兰房产的惊慌失措的搜索。
The after school program that staged the play is a nonprofit called CASA, Children's After School Arts. It was staffed in part by young artsy people, many of whom only worked there part time and seemed to be scraping by in the city, tossed around by the same turbulence.
举办这场戏的课后项目是一个名为CASA（儿童课后艺术）的非营利组织。它由年轻、富有艺术气息的人员部分配备，他们中许多人只是兼职工作，在城市里勉强维持生计，被同样的动荡所折磨。
I'd gotten to know a few of them during the year. They were cool, kind-hearted people. And my daughter loved them. But now it felt like they were indoctrinating my little girl. I was kind of angry at them, even if I was basically sympathetic to their cause.
这一年来，我认识了其中几个。他们是很酷、善良的人。我女儿很爱他们。但现在感觉他们好像在给我的小女儿洗脑。我有点生他们的气，尽管我基本上同情他们的事业。
The cost of living in San Francisco had become the greatest source of anxiety for my family in the last couple of years. We constantly wrestled with whether it was worth trying to live here anymore.
旧金山的生活成本已经成为我家庭过去几年最大的焦虑来源。我们不断纠结是否还有必要在这里生活下去。
But my instinct had been to shield my kids from all that stress and instability, not conscript them. I mean, the only school play I could remember being in as a kid was called Care Bears Class Show. I played a green one.
但我的本能一直是在保护孩子们免受所有的压力和不稳定，而不是强行征召他们。我的意思是，我能记得我小时候参加过的唯一学校剧叫《爱心熊课程秀》。我扮演了一个绿色的。
The play went on. There was a scene about Google buses, a song about FOMO, and a time travel sequence with the ghosts of San Francisco past, present, and future, through the gold rush and the Summer of Love.
戏继续演下去。有一场关于谷歌巴士的戏，一首关于FOMO（错失恐惧症）的歌，以及一段穿越时空的序列，旧金山的过去、现在和未来的幽灵，穿过了淘金热和爱之夏。
My daughter's kindergarten class twirled with flowers in their hair. And there was an impressive cameo by a miniature Allen Ginsberg.
我女儿的幼儿园班级头上戴着花儿在旋转。还有一位微型艾伦·金斯伯格的出色客串。
"I saw the best minds of my generation destroyed by madness, dragging themselves to the streets at dawn, angel-headed hipsters boning for the ancient heavenly connection, the starry dynamo and the machinery of night."
“我看到了我这一代最好的头脑被疯狂摧毁，在黎明时分拖着自己走上街头，天使头的嬉皮士渴望着古老神圣的连接，星辰的发电机和夜晚的机器。”
Here's the plot, though-- spoiler alert, I guess. Ron Scraper's real client turns out to be a shadowy tech corporation, plotting to build something called the Dock.
情节是这样的——剧透预警。罗恩·斯克雷珀的真正客户原来是一家神秘的科技公司，密谋建造一个叫“Dock”的东西。
Ostensibly the Dock is a big, cool cafe with what the kids on stage keep calling top notch, organic, hand-picked, single-sourced, locally-roasted, individually-dripped coffee. But actually, it's a trap. In a later scene, the executives meet to discuss their real plot in private. When San Franciscans come to the Dock and plug in their laptops or phones, the company will install malware on their devices and steal their personal data.
表面上，“Dock”是一个巨大、很酷的咖啡馆，有孩子们在舞台上一直称之为顶级、有机、手工挑选、单一来源、本地烘焙、单独滴滤的咖啡。但实际上，这是一个陷阱。在后面的一场戏中，高管们私下讨论他们的真正阴谋。当旧金山市民来到“Dock”并插上他们的笔记本电脑或手机时，该公司将会在他们的设备上安装恶意软件并窃取个人数据。
Soon this beautiful city will belong to Scraper advertising and ICU Technologies.
很快这座美丽的城市将属于斯克雷珀广告和ICU科技公司。
[EVIL LAUGHTER]
（邪恶的笑声）
See, that's the name of their privacy-breaching, data-scraping tech company, ICU Technologies. As the plot unspools, of course the company has to evict someone.
你看，这就是他们那家侵犯隐私、刮取数据的科技公司的名字，ICU科技。随着剧情展开，公司当然必须驱逐某人。
And it's a close-knit group of multicultural tenants from an old Victorian at 1906 Babylon Lane. The tenants line up in front of their stoop like a row of glum Rockettes and seeing the eviction blues.
是一群来自巴比伦巷1906号一栋旧维多利亚式建筑里的多文化租户。租户们像一排沮丧的火箭女郎一样在门口排成一行，唱着驱逐蓝调。
[SINGING] They're taking the floor from under our feet. Yes, they're taking the floor from right here under our feet. We want to keep fighting, but we're already beat.
（唱歌）他们正在夺走我们脚下的地板。是的，他们正在夺走我们脚下的地板。我们想继续战斗，但我们已经被打败了。
It was here, during this number, that I suddenly realized why my daughter had turned to me out of nowhere on the way home from school a couple of weeks earlier and asked whether our landlords planned to evict us. It surprised me she even knew that word.
就是在这里，在这一曲中，我突然意识到为什么我女儿两周前在放学回家的路上会没来由地问我，我们的房东是否计划驱逐我们。我惊讶于她竟然知道那个词。
[SINGING] The broken heart. I've got to move. I don't know what I'm gonna do. Eviction blues.
（唱歌）破碎的心。我得搬走。我不知道我该怎么办。驱逐蓝调。
The eviction song killed. Everything killed, which was strange, given something I haven't mentioned til now. Maybe half the parents in the auditorium actually worked in tech.
驱逐之歌简直绝了。一切都绝了，这很奇怪，考虑到我到现在还没提的一件事。也许观众席上一半的家长实际上都在科技行业工作。
And now they were watching their own children spear them as cartoon villains, literally cackling and throwing money over flutes of champagne, as they plotted the eviction of all those nice people. No one in the audience booed, of course, or huffed or stamped out. We were watching our kids perform.
现在他们正看着自己的孩子把他们当成卡通恶棍来攻击，一边喝着香槟长笛一边疯狂大笑，密谋驱逐那些好人。当然，观众席上没有人嘘声、哼气或跺脚离开。我们在看孩子们的表演。
But I can't imagine what it must have been like to keep smiling along as you suddenly realized that for weeks after school your own son or daughter had been rehearsing songs that mocked both you and the job you were off busy working, which is why you'd been forced to entrust your kids to the after school program in the first place.
但我无法想象，当你突然意识到几周来放学后你自己的儿子或女儿一直在排练嘲笑你和你忙着去工作的工作的歌曲时，那是种什么感受。而你也是因为那份工作，才被迫把孩子托付给课后项目。
I later heard that one father in the tech industry had gotten wind of the play's plot and actually written to the director, expressing concern. This led to a long, explanatory email to all us parents with the subject line, "Is the CASA musical anti-tech?"
我后来听说一位科技行业的父亲听说了这出戏的剧情，竟然给导演写信表达了担忧。这导致了一封写给所有家长的长长的解释邮件，主题行是：“CASA音乐剧是反科技的吗？”
The short answer is no, the director wrote. The characters are fictional exaggerations and no one group can be blamed for San Francisco's struggles. That said, she insisted, we do not attempt to answer questions with our art, but rather to ask questions.
简短的回答是，不，导演写道。角色是虚构的夸张，没有任何一个群体应该为旧金山的挣扎受到指责。尽管如此，她坚持说，我们不试图用艺术回答问题，而是通过艺术提出问题。
[SINGING] Eviction blues. [HUMMING]
（唱歌）驱逐蓝调。（哼唱）
After the "Eviction Blues," the curtain fell on act one-- intermission. And we all filtered into the courtyard for paella and juice boxes. A neighbor of mine who works in tech walked over.
在“驱逐蓝调”之后，第一幕落幕了——中场休息。我们都走到庭院去吃西班牙海鲜饭和果汁盒。我的一位从事科技行业的邻居走了过来。
And I noticed he felt compelled to lead with a good humored joke about how he hoped I didn't mind chatting with the enemy. I took it as his way, subconsciously at least, to show he was brushing it off. There were no hard feelings. We weren't the caricatures we'd been watching on stage.
我注意到他不得不用一个幽默的笑话开场，说他希望我不介意和敌人聊天。我认为这是他的一种方式，至少在潜意识里，表明他是在不以为然。没有什么硬伤。我们不是我们在台上看到的那些漫画人物。
The real truth was in this interaction, him and me. And he was right. His family was wonderful. We'd spent Halloween at their place. And one night, when I sliced my finger open cooking, I'd run over. And his wife, an ER doctor, cleaned me up and assured me I wouldn't need stitches while I bled all over their kitchen sink.
真实的真相在于这种互动，他和我。他是对的。他的家庭很好。我们在他们家过万圣节。有天晚上我做饭切伤了手指，我跑了过去。他的妻子，一位急诊室医生，帮我清理了伤口，并向我保证我不需要缝针，当时我血流满地，弄脏了他们的厨房水槽。
All that familiarity colored our conversation at intermission. And yet, I'd be lying if I said that in that moment I wasn't also conscious of something else, that my growing family couldn't afford to rent a bigger apartment in our neighborhood, that our days were numbered. And that he, meanwhile, had recently bid up their house across the street to 25% over asking. I hated that I was thinking about that, but I was. And I hated to think that he might be thinking about it too.
所有的熟悉感都给我们在中场休息时的谈话增添了色彩。然而，如果我说在那一刻我没有意识到其他的事情，那我就是在撒谎：我们日益壮大的家庭负担不起在我们的社区租更大的公寓，我们的日子屈指可数。而他，与此同时，最近把街对面的房子竞价到了高出要价25%的水平。我讨厌我在想那个，但我确实在想。我讨厌认为他可能也在想那个。
But at the same time-- and I'm definitely not proud of this-- I also hated that maybe he wasn't thinking about it, that he had the luxury not to, that, as we stood there laughing off the play together, his laughter might have been unencumbered, casual laughter, and not uncomfortable laughter, not even slightly uncomfortable.
但与此同时——我绝对不为此感到自豪——我也讨厌他可能没在想那个，他有奢侈的条件不去想。当我们站在那里一起嘲笑这场戏时，他的笑声可能是无负担的、随意的笑声，而不是不舒服的笑声，甚至连一点点不舒服都没有。
I was embarrassed to recognize all those high pitched voices in the play, stammering their shakily memorized platitudes. They were the voices in my head.
我感到尴尬，因为我认出了戏里那些尖锐的声音，结结巴巴地背诵着颤抖的陈词滥调。那是我脑子里的声音。
It's all the techies' fault. Everything was just fine before they moved in. Hey, does anyone have a phone with power? I really need to get online.
都是科技人员的错。在他们搬进来之前一切都好好的。嘿，有人有带电的手机吗？我真的需要上网。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
The techies are not the enemies. We are also dependent on the technological advances that they have brought.
科技人员不是敌人。我们也依赖于他们带来的技术进步。
Yeah, some of my best friends are techies.
是啊，我最好的朋友里也有科技人员。
The real enemies are selfishness and greed.
真正的敌人是自私和贪婪。
What's wrong with selfishness and greed? We all have to look out for ourselves, right?
自私和贪婪有什么错？我们都得为自己着想，对吧？
That was last May. We don't live in San Francisco anymore. We moved a couple of months later. We still loved living in the city. But life there had started to feel impossible for us in the long term, for reasons which were apparently close enough to what was unfolding on that stage that at some point in act two my wife started to cry.
那是去年五月。我们不再住在旧金山了。几个月后我们搬走了。我们仍然喜欢在城市里的生活。但那里的生活对于我们长期来说已经开始感到不可能了，原因显然与台上正在上演的情节非常接近，以至于在第二幕的某个时候我妻子开始哭泣。
We were lucky to have options. We went somewhere small, semi-rural, and far away, a place where we could afford to buy a pretty cool house and work a little less, and where the children's theater program in town is satisfied doing "Mary Poppins."
我们很幸运有选择。我们去了某个小地方，半农村，很遥远，一个我们负担得起买一栋相当不错的房子、工作稍微少一点的地方，而且那里镇上的儿童剧团满足于表演《玛丽·波平斯》。
Sometimes, up here, I think about that class play. And I can measure how long we've been gone from the Bay Area by how impossible that performance, how impossible the very idea of an elementary school musical about eviction, has started to feel.
有时，在这里，我会想到那出学校剧。我可以衡量我们离开湾区多久了，通过那场表演——那关于驱逐的小学音乐剧的想法本身——开始感觉有多么不可能。
When I think about it now I don't feel the same discomfort, like I'm watching all my own agonizing worries performed in song. What I mostly feel is pride-- pride that my kid got to be a part of it, and pride that she got to live in a place where people cared so deeply about what their city should be that even children's musical theater seemed like a way to hash that question out.
当我现在想到它时，我没有同样的难受，就像我在看我自己所有痛苦的担忧在歌声中表演出来一样。我最大的感受是自豪——自豪我的孩子能成为其中的一员，自豪她能生活在一个人们如此深切关心他们的城市应该是什么样子的地方，以至于连儿童音乐剧似乎都成了探讨这个问题的途径。
And they loved their city so much that inevitably they felt compelled to give their musical a happy ending, even if it meant lacing the last act with a series of preposterous plot twists.
他们太热爱他们的城市了，以至于不可避免地觉得有义务给他们的音乐剧一个快乐的结局，即使这意味着在最后一幕中编织一系列荒谬的情节转折。
The mayor suddenly realizes he's been duped by Scraper Advertising and ICU Technologies.
市长突然意识到他被斯克雷珀广告和ICU科技公司骗了。
I had no idea! I would never approve such a horrible plan! The tenants of 1906 Babylon Lane will not be evicted from their home.
我根本不知道！我绝不会批准如此可怕的计划！巴比伦巷1906号的租户不会被从他们的家里驱逐出去。
[CHEERING]
（欢呼）
Even Ron Scraper comes around.
连罗恩·斯克雷珀也回心转意了。
Oh, fine. Scraper Advertising and ICU Technologies will be working together to provide affordable housing to the people of San Francisco.
噢，好吧。斯克雷珀广告和ICU科技公司将合作，为旧金山人民提供保障性住房。
[CHEERING]
（欢呼）
San Francisco, where you can afford to live!
旧金山，在这里你负担得起生活！
[CHEERING]
（欢呼）
That's a lead in to the plays big final number, a huge demonstration in front of San Francisco's City Hall, with the entire K through 5 ensemble marching down the aisles and out of the wings. They're activists now, pouring onstage, holding signs, and singing about how they've had enough.
那是通往戏里最伟大终曲的引导，在旧金山市政厅前的一场巨大示威，整个K-5年级的合唱团沿着过道和侧翼走出。他们现在是活动家了，涌上舞台，举着标语，唱着关于他们如何受够了的故事。
[SINGING] We've gotta shake, shake, shake things up. We got mad enough. We've got to scream and yell and shout and wail. The city's not for sale. The city's not for sale. The city's not for sale.
（唱歌）我们要震撼，震撼，震撼一切。我们受够了。我们必须尖叫、呐喊、大叫和哀号。这座城市不卖。这座城市不卖。这座城市不卖。
My daughter is barely four feet tall, a sometimes bashful little girl who has trouble pronouncing gentrifier correctly. And onstage, just then, she was absolutely dwarfed by an older, louder kid behind her, who was waving a massive placard that read "resistance equals love of community."
我女儿身高不到四英尺，是一个有时羞怯的小女孩，连gentrifier（中产阶级化者）这个词都发不准。在舞台上，在那一刻，她被身后一个更大、声音更响的孩子完全淹没了，那个孩子正挥舞着一张巨大的标语，上面写着“抵抗等于热爱社区”。
Still, I'm glad to have the memory of her up there, on the fringes of the resistance, mouthing the words.
尽管如此，我很高兴有她站在那里，在抵抗的边缘，嘴里念着歌词的记忆。
[SINGING] The city's not for sale. The city's not for sale.
（唱歌）这座城市不卖。这座城市不卖。
Jon Mooallem is a contributing writer to The New York Times Magazine.
乔恩·穆阿勒姆是《纽约时报杂志》的特约撰稿人。
Coming up, a two-word slogan that changed the direction of an entire nation. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来的节目，一个改变整个国家方向的双词口号。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program- "The Poetry of Propaganda," stories of how propaganda can contain complicated and subtle messages, even propaganda that does not seem so subtle when you first encounter it. We've arrived at act three of our program.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目——“宣传的诗学”，关于宣传如何包含复杂而微妙的信息的故事，即使是那些在你初次接触时看起来并不那么微妙的宣传。我们已经到了节目的第三幕。
Act Three, "The Spy Who Did Not Know She Was a Spy." OK, so here's something that rarely ever happens in this country. Just this week a US government agency was found guilty of disseminating covert propaganda, perpetrating covert propaganda on the American public.
第三幕，“不知道自己是间谍的间谍”。好吧，这里发生了一件在这个国家极少发生的事情。就在本周，一个美国政府机构被认定犯有散布秘密宣传、在美国公众身上进行秘密宣传的罪行。
And this was not the CIA. It was not the NSA. These were the tree huggers over at the Environmental Protection Agency who did this. The ruling this week by the Government Accountability Office said that the EPA had used everyday citizens in this nefarious scheme.
这可不是中央情报局。也不是国家安全局。这是环境保护署（EPA）那群拥抱树木的人做的。政府问责局本周的裁决称，EPA在这个邪恶的计划中使用了普通公民。
[PHONE RINGING]
（电话铃声）
Hello?
喂？
Hey, is this Marion?
嘿，是马里昂吗？
This is.
是。
I reached one of those everyday citizens, Marion Leary. She's a medical researcher in Philadelphia.
我联系到了那些普通公民之一，马里昂·利里。她是费城的一名医学研究员。
Did you know that you have been perpetrating covert propaganda on behalf of the United States government?
你知道你一直在代表美国政府进行秘密宣传吗？
I did not know I was perpetrating covert information. What are you referring to?
我不知道我一直在进行秘密信息传播。你指的是什么？
I'm referring to a tweet you made on the 29th of September where you said, "Clean water is important to me. I support EPA's efforts to protect it for my health, my family, and my community."
我指的是你在9月29日发的一条推特，你说，“清洁的水对我来说很重要。我支持EPA保护它的努力，为了我的健康、我的家人和我的社区。”
OK.
好的。
Do you recognize that tweet at all?
你认得那条推特吗？
I'd have to go back. It sounds like something I would tweet, though. I support clean water.
我得回去看看。但这听起来像我会发推文的内容。我支持清洁的水。
OK, here's what this is about. The Government Accountability Office says in its ruling that because of social media, there is a whole new way that federal agencies can mess up when they communicate with the public.
好吧，这就是关于这件事的。政府问责局在裁决中表示，由于社交媒体，联邦机构在与公众沟通时有一种全新的方式会搞砸。
And the EPA messed up with a campaign where they went out on social media and they told the world, OK, we're proposing a new rule to keep pollution out of drinking water. That part of it was actually totally fine.
而EPA搞砸了一个活动，他们去社交媒体上告诉世界，好吧，我们正在提议一项新的规则，以防止污染进入饮用水。那部分实际上完全没问题。
Where the EPA got into trouble was when they said to the public, if you like our new proposed rule, send out a tweet with this wording. And the wording they suggested was exactly what Marion and hundreds of other people used.
EPA遇到麻烦的地方在于他们对公众说，如果你喜欢我们提议的新规则，就用这段话发一条推特。他们建议的措辞正是马里昂和成百上千人所使用的。
And the problem with was that while the EPA's original message was clearly labeled as coming from a federal agency-- it had the EPA log, it had EPA's-- the message Marion sent out, and all these other people sent out to their friends and followers, those messages didn't make clear that the EPA was behind the whole thing.
问题在于，虽然EPA最初的信息清楚地标记为来自联邦机构——它有EPA的标志，有EPA的……——但马里昂发出的信息，以及所有其他人发给朋友和粉丝的信息，那些信息没有清楚地表明EPA是幕后黑手。
Edda Emmanuelli Perez is the GAO lawyer who oversaw the drafting of this ruling for the GAO.
埃达·埃马努埃利·佩雷斯是GAO的律师，负责监督这项裁决的起草。
So even though EPA had written the message, it was written in such a way-- it said, "I support efforts," for example, "for clean water," or "I support EPA's efforts."
所以尽管是EPA写的信息，但它的写法是——例如，它说“我支持努力”，“为了清洁的水”，或者“我支持EPA的努力”。
The public, in that sense, would not be able to tell that EPA wrote this message. And so that's a problem. Because the whole purpose of the covert propaganda prohibition is to make sure that when the government is providing information, it needs to clearly identify itself as the source.
公众在那种意义上，无法分辨出是EPA写了这条信息。所以那是个问题。因为秘密宣传禁令的全部目的是确保政府在提供信息时，需要清楚地说明自己是来源。
She says it's as if a government agency hired a spokesman to go on TV and talk up its programs, but the spokesman never revealed to anybody that he was being paid by the agency. He just acted like everything he was saying, praising the policies, were just beliefs that he had come to, on his own, just his personal opinion.
她说这就像一个政府机构雇了一个发言人去电视上吹嘘他们的项目，但发言人从不向任何人透露他是被该机构付钱的。他只是表现得好像他所说的一切，赞扬这些政策，都只是他自己得出的信念，只是他个人的观点。
Which of course, make sense. But what complicates it is that for Marion, the woman who I talked to from Philly, and probably for lots of people who repeated the EPA's message verbatim, they agreed with the message. It was their personal opinion. Nobody paid them. Nobody made them tweet.
这当然有道理。但复杂的是，对于马里昂，我交谈过的那位费城女士，以及可能许多逐字重复EPA信息的人来说，他们同意这个信息。这是他们个人的观点。没有人付钱给他们。没有人强迫他们发推。
If it was something that I didn't agree with, then I probably would be very upset about that. But I chose to retweet that. I agree with the importance of clean water. I'm an EPA supporter.
如果那是我不同意的东西，那么我可能会对此感到非常不安。但我选择了转发那条推特。我同意清洁水的重要性。我是EPA的支持者。
What I'm getting from this conversation is you don't care that you were covert propaganda. You don't give a damn.
我从这段对话中得到的是，你并不在意你成了秘密宣传。你根本不在乎。
Not really. Propaganda does sound ugly. But it is a person who promotes or publicizes a particular cause. And I think social media, in general, but Twitter especially-- gives a platform to anybody to be able to be a propaganda-ist.
并不在意。宣传听起来确实很丑。但它是一个推广或宣传特定事业的人。我认为社交媒体，总的来说，尤其是推特——给了任何人一个成为宣传者的平台。
So then I guess I would call myself a propagandist. I don't know if I'd call myself a covert one.
那我想我会称自己为宣传者。我不知道我是否会称自己为秘密的那种。
Well, I think the covert refers to the fact that you're hiding your very close association with the federal government of the United States of America. You're hiding the fact that you are just their puppet, doing their bidding.
好吧，我想“秘密”指的是你在隐藏你与美利坚合众国联邦政府非常密切的联系这一事实。你在隐藏你是他们傀儡、听命于他们的事实。
I'm definitely not the government's puppet doing their bidding. So on that claim, I would dispute that. But definitely, I could see myself putting out some good propaganda around issues that I think are important for everyone.
我绝对不是政府听命于他们的傀儡。所以关于那个主张，我会反驳。但绝对的，我可以看到自己在我认为对每个人都很重要的问题上发布一些好的宣传。
I like how over the course of this phone call, you've gone from having no idea about the propaganda to being a little horrified by it. And now you're embracing it.
我喜欢在这通电话的过程中，你从对宣传一无所知，到对此感到有点震惊。而现在你正在拥抱它。
Well, it took me a while to catch up.
好吧，我花了一段时间才跟上节奏。
Let me just ask you, have your feelings about Joseph Stalin changed over the course of this brief phone conversation?
让我问你，你对约瑟夫·斯大林的看法在这段简短的通话中改变了吗？
[LAUGHING]
（笑声）
They have not.
没有。
In case you're wondering, the head of the EPA not be doing prison time for breaking this federal rule, nor will President Obama, nor will Marion. The likely penalty is that the EPA will have to return the money they spent on this social media campaign to the United States Treasury.
以防你想知道，EPA的负责人不会因为违反这条联邦规则而坐牢，奥巴马总统也不会，马里昂也不会。可能的惩罚是EPA将不得不把他们在这个社交媒体活动上花费的钱归还给美国财政部。
And they'll have to issue a report basically admitting that they were wrong, which is unclear if that's going to happen. The EPA says that it does not agree with the GAO ruling. They declined to be interviewed. But a spokesperson told us this is not over.
他们将不得不发表一份报告，基本上承认他们错了，目前还不清楚那是否会发生。EPA表示不同意GAO的裁决。他们拒绝接受采访。但一位发言人告诉我们，这还没结束。
Of course, the federal government uses everyday citizens to disseminate its messages all the time. And it doesn't get called propaganda. When a fourth grade teacher explains the food pyramid and does not tell the class that it comes from the USDA and HHS, that is not against the law. When your doctor suggests a flu shot and doesn't mention that she's just parroting the official line on flu shots from the CDC, she is not a covert propagandist.
当然，联邦政府一直都在使用普通公民来传播他们的信息。而那并没有被称为宣传。当一位四年级老师解释食物金字塔，而不告诉班级它来自美国农业部和卫生与公众服务部时，那并不违法。当你的医生建议打流感疫苗而不提她只是在鹦鹉学舌CDC关于流感疫苗的官方说法时，她不是秘密宣传者。
And the difference between those things and what the EPA did is actually one very specific detail. The GAO lawyer, Edda Emmanuelli Perez, says that detail-- the EPA suggested the exact words that it wanted people to tweet. And it was misleading.
那些事情与EPA所做的事情之间的区别实际上是一个非常具体的细节。GAO律师埃达·埃马努埃利·佩雷斯说，那个细节——EPA建议了它希望人们推文的具体词汇。而且那是具有误导性的。
When you look at that message, it says I support EPA's efforts you know, to protect my health, et cetera. The I in that sentence sounds like it's that person, from whose account the messages is being generated.
当你看着那条信息，它说我支持EPA的努力，你知道，保护我的健康等等。那句话里的“我”听起来就像是那个账户持有人的个人声音。
But that sentence was written by EPA. And they crafted the message and got someone else to say it for them.
但那句话是EPA写的。他们精心制作了这条信息，并让别人替他们说出来。
Are there federal rules against overt propaganda?
有反对公开宣传的联邦规则吗？
I'm not aware of any.
我不了解任何此类规则。
You heard that right. It may be illegal for the EPA to do what it did. But overt propaganda-- spin, obfuscation, lying, overstating evidence-- when it's done by the president, when it's done by members of Congress, they would actually have to defraud the United States government, or like, an official would need to commit a high crime worthy of constitutional action, to get in trouble. Overt propaganda-- that's just politics.
你听清楚了。EPA做它所做的事情可能是违法的。但公开宣传——炒作、混淆、撒谎、夸大证据——当总统这样做时，当国会议员这样做时，他们实际上必须欺诈美国政府，或者像，一名官员需要犯下值得宪法行动的重罪，才能惹上麻烦。公开宣传——那只是政治。
Act Four, "Party On." So to end our show today we have the story of a very effective, and perhaps counter-intuitive, propaganda campaign that started in China, right in the aftermath of Tiananmen Square.
第四幕，“继续派对”。所以为了结束我们今天的节目，我们要讲述一个非常有效，也许是反直觉的宣传活动的故事，它始于中国，就在天安门广场事件的余波中。
Of course, Tiananmen Square was 1989. The government killed an unknown number of people-- at least hundreds, possibly 2,000, many of them students, who'd been calling for democracy and other changes.
当然，天安门广场事件是在1989年。政府杀死了一个未知数量的人——至少数百人，可能2000人，其中许多是呼吁民主和其他变革的学生。
Nancy Updike talked to Evan Osnos. He's a staff writer for The New Yorker who spent seven years reporting in China about how the Chinese leadership adapted in the aftermath.
南希·厄普戴克与埃文·奥斯诺斯交谈过。他是《纽约客》的一名特约撰稿人，在中国报道了七年，内容关于中国领导层在事后是如何适应的。
The country's leaders were shocked by the demonstrations at Tiananmen. Because until then, for 40 years, they had been deploying a package of propaganda that worked.
这个国家的领导人被天安门的示威活动震惊了。因为在那之前，40年来，他们一直部署着一套行之有效的宣传方案。
Its message was the Communist Party brought a glorious transformation to China. The country was the envy of the world because of that transformation. It had the best political system possible.
其信息是共产党为中国带来了辉煌的转型。由于这种转型，中国成为世界羡慕的对象。它拥有尽可能最好的政治制度。
And the party had made everyone's lives better. And the government thought most people accepted that, until Tiananmen filled up with students and others who had clearly been seduced by foreign notions.
而且党让每个人的生活都变得更好了。政府认为大多数人接受了这一点，直到天安门挤满了学生和其他显然被外国观念诱惑的人们。
That was, by any definition, a failure of Chinese education and propaganda. That's how the party viewed it.
无论怎么定义，那都是中国教育和宣传的失败。这就是党看待它的方式。
That's Evan Osnos.
那是埃文·奥斯诺斯。
In fact, for a while they talked about getting rid of the propaganda department. They said it's been such a failure. But instead of getting rid of it, they, in fact, doubled down on it.
实际上，有一段时间他们谈论过撤销宣传部。他们说这已经成了如此大的失败。但他们没有撤销它，实际上，反而加倍投入了。
They doubled down, but not in the way you'd expect, not by getting even more shrill about the greatness of the nation and the happiness of the people. The party could see that people weren't buying it anymore.
他们加倍投入，但不是以你预料的方式，不是通过对国家伟大和人民幸福变得更加尖锐地叫嚣。党可以看到人们不再买账了。
And they weren't buying it because the truth was too stark. After four decades of communist rule, people were not as poor as they'd been, though they were still poor. But the thing that was really getting to them was the blatant corruption.
而且他们不买账是因为真相太赤裸了。在四十年的共产主义统治之后，人们并不像以前那么穷，尽管他们仍然贫穷。但真正触动他们的是肆无忌惮的腐败。
They couldn't help noticing that party members and their families kept getting richer and richer. For some in China, a dangerous idea had taken root, that maybe people elsewhere had it better.
他们无法不注意到党员及其家属变得越来越富有。对于中国的一些人来说，一个危险的想法已经扎根，也许其他地方的人生活得更好。
What the government needed at this point was not some upbeat slogan, but a radical new approach to explaining why foreign notions were a trap and why communism was still the best path for China.
政府在这一点上需要的不是什么令人振奋的口号，而是一种解释为什么外国观念是一个陷阱，为什么共产主义仍然是中国最好路径的激进新方法。
This new idea had to be something big. It couldn't admit mistakes or failures of any kind by communist leaders. And it would be great if this new idea had some truth in it, because truth is the magic ingredient in strong propaganda. What the party decided on was--
这个新想法必须是宏大的。它不能承认共产党领导人的任何错误或失败。如果这个新想法能包含一些真理就太好了，因为真理是强大宣传的魔法成分。党决定的是——
Guochi, national humiliation. The term itself is wuwang guochi, never forget national humiliation.
国耻。这个术语本身就是“勿忘国耻”。
Humiliation, in this context, has a precise meaning.
在这种背景下，“耻辱”有着精确的含义。
It means defeat at the hands of foreign armies. It means invasion.
它意味着在外军手中的失败。它意味着入侵。
It's hard to overestimate how shrewd this move by the party was, to build nationalism by focusing on the country's defeats. I think to Americans this idea makes no sense.
很难高估党这一举措的精明，通过关注国家的失败来建立民族主义。我认为对美国人来说，这个想法完全没道理。
In the United States we occasionally talk about moments when we were underdogs-- the American Revolution, for instance. But that's only because we came out on top. In general, we see ourselves as a nation of righteous ass kickers. But we're a very young country.
在美国，我们偶尔谈论我们作为失败者的时刻——例如美国独立战争。但那只是因为我们最终赢了。总的来说，我们认为自己是一个正义的踢屁股国家。但我们是一个非常年轻的国家。
And unlike China, we've never had the terrifying, humiliating experience of being invaded and occupied. China, in the 19th and 20th centuries, had been invaded multiple times, plundered by foreigners year after year after year.
而且不像中国，我们从未有过被入侵和占领的那种可怕、屈辱的经历。中国在19世纪和20世纪被多次入侵，年复一年地被外国人掠夺。
National humiliation was not a new idea for China when the party reintroduced it in the 1990s. It was an old idea that had fallen out of fashion.
当党在90年代重新引入“国耻”时，这对于中国来说并不是一个新想法。这是一个早已过时的旧想法。
They dusted off this old idea from Chinese history that went all the way back to the beginning of the 20th century. And they said here it is, humiliation. Humiliation has been marketed in China, in a way. Quite literally, it's been marketing.
他们拂去了中国历史中一直追溯到20世纪初的这个旧想法。他们说这就是它，耻辱。耻辱在中国被营销过，在某种程度上。真的是字面意义上的，这是一种营销。
At one point, in the '20s, there was a Chinese newspaper that was selling national humiliation towels so that people could wash their face every day and remember national humiliation. Because they're towel would remind them of that.
有一次，在20年代，有一家中国报纸在销售国耻毛巾，这样人们可以每天洗脸时记住国耻。因为他们的毛巾会提醒他们。
And in the '90s, in the years after Tienanmen Square, the whole apparatus of government was basically enlisted in service of making sure that young people were thinking about the ways in which the country had been harmed by foreigners over the course of their history.
而在90年代，在天安门广场事件后的几年里，整个政府机构基本上都被征募来确保年轻人思考这个国家在他们的历史上被外国人伤害的方式。
National humiliation became a central concept in China after 1991-- in educational materials, in films, in textbooks, including a brand new textbook called--
国耻在1991年后的中国成为了一个核心概念——在教育材料、电影、教科书中，包括一本名为——
The Practical Dictionary of Patriotic Education. And it included 355 pages on the subject of China's humiliations. So that included battles that China had lost, and places in which foreign soldiers had killed civilians, for instance.
《爱国主义教育实用词典》的全新教科书。它包含了355页关于中国耻辱的主题。包括中国输掉的战役，以及外国士兵杀害平民的地方，等等。
And there were these terms that became very important. So for instance, one of the things that they taught, over and over again, was called the bainian guochi, or the century of national humiliation.
而且有一些变得非常重要的术语。例如，他们一遍又一遍教的一件事，被称为“百年国耻”。
The century of national humiliation was a name for the 100 years starting from the first Opium War, when Britain forced China to cede Hong Kong, up through the brutal Japanese occupation of parts of China before and during the Second World War.
“百年国耻”是给那100年的名称，从第一次鸦片战争开始，当时英国强迫中国割让香港，一直到第二次世界大战前及期间日本对中国部分地区的残暴占领。
To commemorate the century national humiliation, the Chinese government built museums and designated dozens of sites all over the country in the '90s, including many places of defeat and invasion.
为了纪念百年国耻，中国政府在90年代在全国范围内建造了博物馆并指定了几十个地点，包括许多失败和入侵的地方。
Places that, really, previously nobody had cared about, the sites of old battle and things. And they started turning these into sacred sites. And that was some of the language they used. They used this really religious language.
实际上以前没人关心过的地方，旧战场之类的地点。他们开始将这些变成神圣的地点。那就是他们使用的一些语言。他们使用了这种真正的宗教语言。
These became part of normal education. You would go there on field trips. For instance, students were expected to go to a certain number of field trips by the time they graduated from middle school to patriotic education sites.
这些成了正规教育的一部分。你会进行实地考察去那里。例如，学生在初中毕业前预计要进行一定次数的实地考察去爱国主义教育基地。
You would go to places in China and you would see references to this subject of guochi, national humiliation. You'd see it inscribed, for instance, on the wall, at the front of a museum.
你会去中国的各个地方，你会看到关于这个国耻主题的参考文献。你会看到它被铭刻，例如，在博物馆正面的墙上。
Inside the Communist Party, it became a frenzy to see who could support the idea of national humiliation most vehemently, most perfectly.
在共产党内部，谁能最强烈、最完美地支持国耻理念，成了一种狂热。
The National People's Congress approved a holiday called National Humiliation Day. But then there was too much enthusiasm. There were so many proposals in the Congress for which day that should be. And some people wanted it to be September 18.
全国人民代表大会批准了一个节日，叫“国耻日”。但后来热情太高了。国会中关于那应该是哪一天的提议太多了。有些人想它是9月18日。
September 18, the beginning of Japan's occupation of Manchuria.
9月18日，日本占领满洲的开始。
And some people wanted it to be September 7.
有些人想它是9月7日。
The day of defeat for a Chinese uprising against the British and others.
中国起义对抗英国和其他人的失败之日。
And some people said no, no. It should be in June.
有些人说不，不。它应该在六月。
In June there had been a massacre in the 1920s.
六月在20年代发生过一次大屠杀。
They couldn't agree on one. And so they didn't end up instituting it.
他们无法就一天达成一致。所以他们最终没有确立它。
Are we recording? Yes, we are.
我们在录音吗？是的，我们在录。
Great.
太棒了。
I called a young Chinese woman named Shu Cao Mo. She's part of that first generation of Chinese students who were taught this new, post-Tienanmen curriculum.
我打电话给了一位名叫舒曹莫的中国年轻女性。她是第一代接受了这种新的、后天安门课程的中国学生的一部分。
Shu Cao left China for college. She came to the US, to Duke University. She still lives here. She remembers, as a kid, learning the key phrases, national humiliation, century of humiliation, how foreigners had invaded and abused China, until the Communist Party came to power in a great revolution.
舒曹为了读大学离开了中国。她来到美国，杜克大学。她仍然住在这里。她记得，小时候学习关键短语，国耻，百年国耻，外国人是如何入侵和虐待中国的，直到共产党在伟大的革命中掌权。
Details of the revolution were omitted-- mass starvation, torture, ideological conformity at all costs.
革命的细节被遗漏了——大规模饥荒、酷刑、不惜一切代价的意识形态一致。
It was really this sense of this humiliation, this century of humiliation, legitimizes revolution. And in the textbooks, what I kept learning was how we had those revolutionary heroes who are supposed to be our role models.
这真的是一种这种耻辱感，这种百年国耻，使革命合法化。在教科书中，我不断学习的是我们如何拥有那些本应作为我们榜样的革命英雄。
These stories about revolutionary heroes appeared throughout the curriculum, often without using the words "national humiliation" at all. The phrase was only the most blunt, noticeable part of the campaign.
这些关于革命英雄的故事贯穿了课程，通常根本不使用“国耻”这两个字。这个短语只是该活动最直白、最引人注目的部分。
Shu Cao says the concept was embedded all over, especially in stories. In college, she got a scholarship to look at how nationalism is taught in children's books, including textbooks, in three places-- the US, Germany, and China.
舒曹说这个概念被嵌入到各处，尤其是在故事中。在大学里，她获得了一笔奖学金，去观察民族主义是如何在儿童书籍中被教授的，包括教科书，在三个地方——美国、德国和中国。
For her project, she went back to China and looked at the books she had studied growing up. And she also fact checked some of the stories she remembered learning as a kid.
为了她的项目，她回到中国，看了她成长过程中学习的书。她还核实了她小时候记得的一些故事。
And it was a strange experience. One of these hero stories, she found out, had been modified dramatically in textbooks in order to amp up the humiliation. It was the story about the five martyrs.
那是一次奇怪的经历。这些英雄故事中的一个，她发现，在教科书中被大幅修改了，为了增加耻辱感。那就是关于五个烈士的故事。
Who jumped off the cliff in order to save the larger Chinese Army from the Japanese. In Chinese, we call it [CHINESE]. You sacrifice your small self in order to complete the larger whole.
为了拯救更大的中国军队免受日本人侵害，他们跳下了悬崖。在中文里，我们称之为“舍小我，成大我”。
That's what that phrase means, mm hm?
那个短语就是那个意思，嗯？
Yeah. And I had always thought that they were dead, because they had sacrificed their lives. And it was only two years ago, when I was doing that research, that I found out that half of them were still alive.
是的。我一直认为他们死了，因为他们牺牲了生命。而直到两年前，当我做那项研究时，我才发现他们中一半人还活着。
It's definitely a better national humiliation story if all the martyrs died, not just some. Shu Cao remembered another story about a Chinese leader, Zhou Enlai, who as a teenager had seen a Chinese woman being bullied by foreign occupiers. And right then, witnessing that humiliation, he realized what he needed to do.
如果所有烈士都死了，而不是只有一部分，那绝对是一个更好的国耻故事。舒曹记得另一个关于一位中国领导人周恩来的故事，他在十几岁时看到一个中国妇女被外国占领者欺负。就在那一刻，目睹那场耻辱，他意识到他需要做什么。
Study for the rise of China. And that phrase was being repeated over and over again in that story. So if you ask any Chinese student, they would know the story and how that became his goal for his life, resurrecting China.
“为中华之崛起而读书”。那个短语在那故事里被一遍又一遍地重复。所以如果你问任何中国学生，他们都会知道那个故事，以及它是如何成为他终身的目标，复兴中国。
Shu Cao hadn't gone to college with the intent of combing through her childhood education. But once she started, she realized how many questions she had built up over the years.
舒曹去上大学并不是为了梳理她的童年教育。但一旦她开始，她意识到她多年来积累了多少疑问。
Growing up in a well-educated family, I had always questioned what's written in my textbooks. I have always questioned what the authority tells me. So it's this slow process of always wondering what's not being said.
成长在一个受过良好教育的家庭，我一直质疑教科书里写的东西。我一直质疑权威告诉我什么。所以这是一个缓慢的过程，总是想知道什么没有被说出来。
What's not said is, of course, what's so ingenious about the whole campaign to revive national humiliation. By focusing the country's attention on foreign attacks, the party was diverting attention from its own errors and abuses.
没说出来的是，当然，这正是复兴国耻整个活动的精妙之处。通过将国家的注意力集中在外国攻击上，党是在转移对其自身错误和滥权的注意力。
It's a classic misdirect. And both Shu Cao and reporter Evan Osnos say it's worked pretty well, especially with the event that the government has wanted to obscure more than just about any other, Tiananmen.
这是一个经典的误导。舒曹和记者埃文·奥斯诺斯都说它运作得相当好，尤其是对于政府想要掩盖多于几乎任何其他事件的天安门事件。
Yeah. A lot of Chinese young people today, to the degree that they know about it-- and the truth is that a lot of Chinese young people know very little about what happened-- what they'll say is that the young people at Tiananmen were naive. And they were tempted by these Western ideas.
是的。今天许多中国年轻人，就他们知道的程度而言——事实是许多中国年轻人对发生的事情知之甚少——他们会说在天安门的年轻人太天真了。而且他们被这些西方思想诱惑了。
But those Western ideas aren't suitable for China, and that, had we gone down that path, we wouldn't be where we are today. We wouldn't be this rising superpower.
但那些西方思想不适合中国，而且，如果我们走了那条路，我们就不会有今天。我们就不会成为这个崛起的超级大国。
So it was a humiliation averted, then, Tiananmen.
所以那天安门是一场避免了的耻辱。
It was. They look at it and they really do say we chose the right path. And it would have been a disaster. So in that sense, the education system has done exactly what it was designed to do.
是的。他们看着它，真的说我们选择了正确的道路。那将是一场灾难。所以从那个意义上讲，教育系统已经完全做到了它被设计要做的。
In 2008, when the Olympics were coming to Beijing, there were demonstrations in China again-- lots of young people, like there were a lot of young people at Tiananmen.
2008年，当奥运会要来到北京时，中国又出现了示威活动——很多年轻人，就像天安门有很多年轻人一样。
But in 2008, what the demonstrators were outraged about was foreigners-- foreigners criticizing China in the run up to the Olympics. These protests were in support of the government.
但在2008年，抗议者愤怒的是外国人——外国人批评中国在奥运会前夕。这些抗议是为了支持政府。
Nancy Updike is a producer for our program. Evan Osnos's book about China, Age of Ambition, won the National Book Award for 2014. It's out in paperback.
南希·厄普戴克是我们节目的制片人。埃文·奥斯诺斯的关于中国的书，《野心时代》，获得了2014年国家图书奖。平装版已经出版。
Our program was produced today by Sean Cole and our senior producer, Brian Reed, Zoe Chace, Neil Drumming, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike.
我们的节目今天由肖恩·科尔和我制作，高级制片人布莱恩·里德，佐伊·蔡斯，尼尔·德拉明，斯蒂芬妮·富，查娜·乔夫-沃尔特，米基·米克，乔纳森·门吉瓦尔，罗宾·塞米恩，阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普戴克制作。
Our editor is Joel Lovell. Julie Snyder's our editorial consultant. Our technical director is Matt Tierney. Production help from Lilly Sullivan. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager.
我们的编辑是乔尔·洛弗尔。朱莉·斯奈德是我们的编辑顾问。我们的技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼。莉莉·沙利文提供了制作帮助。赛斯·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登是我们的制作经理。
Elise Bergerson's our business operations manager. Elma Baker scouts new stories for our show. Kimberly Henderson is our office coordinator. Research help from Christopher Swetala. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
埃莉斯·伯格森是我们的业务运营经理。埃尔玛·贝克为我们的节目搜寻新故事。金伯利·亨德森是我们的办公室协调员。克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉提供了研究帮助。达米恩·格雷夫和罗布·盖迪斯提供了音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢）
The musical, "The City is Not For Sale," in act two of our program today, was written, directed, and produced by Leslie Einhorn, Jeremy Rourke, and Sharon Boggs.
我们节目今天第二幕中的音乐剧《这座城市不卖》，由莱斯利·艾因霍恩、杰里米·鲁尔克和莎伦·博格斯编写、导演和制作。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交换中心发送给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, ever since he returned from his South American vacation he has been moping. He'd been complaining how life here seems so dull.
像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，自从他从南美度假回来后，他就一直闷闷不乐。他一直抱怨这里的生活看起来如此沉闷。
There's no friends. There's no party. There's no aguardiente. There's nothing. There's no fun.
没有朋友。没有派对。没有 aguardiente。什么都没有。没有乐趣。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。